thanks rocky now that school is back in
you may be trying to grab some of those
last minute items from your list but how
about kicking it up a notch and
personalizing those back to school
supplies and clothing joining me to tell
us more is zazzle.com chief brand
officer nizzy renaud how are you nizzy
hi mercedes i'm doing well thank you
here's to back to school i know and i
love zazzle i've been a fan for years
but tell if people don't know what
zazzle is tell them what you can find on
zazzle
sure so zazzle is a global online
marketplace for creating and customizing
unique designs and products and they're
all made on demand and so millions of
people use our site daily and they
express their creativity and they
celebrate life's moments but when they
make that purchase they're actually
supporting a marketplace of creators
licensed brand partners and makers now
you can get
anything on the site i've gotten
t-shirts and coffee cups and all sorts
of great things but as we head back to
school what are some of the great items
that we can customize for ourselves or
for our kids
so we have a great range of customizable
back-to-school products to show you
today everything from dorm and room
decor to school supplies and maybe even
a teacher gift or two and you know
there's a price point for everyone on
zazzle and so everything we're going to
show you today is under 35 dollars we're
looking at some
some dorm sweet dorm uh decor decor for
for those that are maybe going off to
college
yes so
this is an ode to home sweet home with
the dorm suite dorm poster and now it
has a glitter look without that mess of
glitter and you can customize the
background color to match your decor
needs using our easy design tool
those are fabulous what are some of the
other items that you can customize well
i don't know about you but if you have
up there door hangers are a vibe if you
can see those and here if the door
hanger that's up we're letting everyone
know
that we might be studying but if that's
not what you want to communicate the
words here are customizable before you
place your order so if you don't want to
say sh i'm studying you might want to
say i'm sleeping or i'm socializing
those are so great and you can yeah you
can make those say whatever you want to
say
what about labels let's talk a little
bit about some of the labels that you
can make
yeah so we have so many great notepads
we have so many great labels um those
are really fun actual teacher gift
there's nothing like a fun customizable
gift to stand out and who doesn't need
more stickers labels or notepads in
today's digital world there's something
about writing things down on paper we've
got so many of these to choose from that
those really would make a good gift even
for at home but one thing i want to talk
about that i think everyone can use pens
and people steal my pens all the time
but not when they're personalized right
not when they're personalized and in the
spirit of writing things down
personalized pens you can print your
name on these but you know one thing i
really like to do is print messages so i
create sets with words of wisdom like
just breathe be present and they're so
fun they're a thoughtful gift and
they're really practical for yourself
those are great so many fun things thank
you so much check out zazzle.com you
will be on there for hours great stuff
thank you so much nizzy we'll send it
over to you rocky thank you